[Music]
[Applause]
to review a bad comedy is one of the
toughest things to review because
there's only so many times you can say
that's not funny and on top of that only
so much that a person like me can take
so rather than look at this film as a
comedy I'm instead gonna look at it as
cinematic suicide a film that wants to
die and tries everything in its power to
die that way when I shove it up Dana
Carvey x' anal passage I will feel no
guilt whatsoever what that said master
of disguise
I call this movie the crowning
achievement of failure from production
company happy Madison this is Adam
Sandler's production company that seems
to reward the strange phenomenon that
despite someone like Sandler having many
different talents he somehow makes
millions by insultingly using none of
them and thus happy Madison has wanted
to help other comedians make money with
no identifiable effort whatsoever and
because this has adam bombed career
after career after career i don't know
what they do
maybe it's like wow those harry potter
ringwraith ripoff they just come in and
suck out all the money out of here then
one of those often funny comedians that
seemed to suffer from happy mass since
touch of death is then a carving this
was an SNL cast member who had a great
talent for impersonation they had it all
around a beat feel to him he even had a
couple of hit movies with his friend
Mike Myers and Wayne's World and Wayne's
World 2 but his rising star was having
trouble finding a solar system to call
its own and a lot of his projects were
starting to tank and whatever measly
speck of Hope he had left was sodomized
and buried when he wrote and started
this fucking hunk of shit how bad is it
well Rotten Tomatoes has given it 1% and
according to what I hear a lot of
Statistics have a 1% margin of error bad
people that bad so let's see why all of
this is warranted
this is master of disguise really just
1% oh so we start out with some
background text oh wait this is for a
Happy Madison audience they're reading
for them many centuries ago their
remarkable family began to practice the
magical art of disguise
apparently they became so good at this
that in 1979 one of the contrast form
into a 2002 looking Bo Derek this is a
new life for my son I will
never tell him of his true destiny
that's James Brolin playing the father
of our main character was born years
later under the name pistachio disguisey
now you may think that name is fucking
ridiculously obvious but remember again
Happy Madison productions I'm surprised
they don't spell everything out like
this so that their audience doesn't get
confused I Sofia
what an unexpected surprise enough cake
of course the joke is that pistachio is
not very smart but it's okay they at
least wrote in a boatload of charm for
him oh wait they did not excuse a young
man they I couldn't help but notice that
you became acquainted with the sidewalk
a moment ago
pistachio why don't you do one of your
funny voices and sure the kid up you
mean he wasn't already Oh God
is that gonna be the voice he's gonna
use throughout the majority of the movie
can you judge me let me check me right
now come on kill me I know just what are
you doing you said to stick you it was a
joke Rachel oh hey we're just standing
with a syringe in the corner the whole
time you know
so he does one of his many voices for
the kid why don't you get away from me
donkey what'd you talk about get away
from you I'm making waffles well to be
fair wasn't that funny when Shrek didn't
either
oh I see you like my dog what perhaps
your Papa will buy you a dog I never had
a dad like that so what you might have
figured out early on is that Dana Carvey
seems to have the basics of comedy a
little backwards
it's not funny voices and faces that
makes a character it's a character that
makes funny voices and faces and this
one has little to no identity outside of
an over-the-top accent even Mario will
be shouting racists at him watch and
learn my friend oh god the father's
amitabh or is that he's offensive maybe
that's why he can't hold down a
girlfriend for two minutes either look
shows the silly voices and making faces
it was fun for like one second oh my god
that's the movie
that's the movie right there you summed
it up in one sentence how did you do
that something else Carvey sure picked
up it's that character is based on
investment and it's hard to be invested
in someone who clearly is not invested
in anything going on around him but
instead how silly he can make his
performance take a look at this scene
and tell me of Carvey oh I'm sorry the
incredibly fleshed-out pistachio
character shows any signs of caring wait
discovers his mother and father have
been kidnapped
[Music]
please Heavenly Father show me a sign I
promise I will never mock you again my
family is missing and I don't know what
to do I don't know what they do I don't
know what to do yeah he just seems more
occupied in smiling with his mouth open
I think the music is actually trying
harder than he is but cannoli is a
better actor than him right now I always
believe there's a cannoli I don't know
what to do I don't know it
yes go lie down being unfunny can take a
lot out of you so they make an exorcist
joke because it existed and he's visited
by his grandfather who says he can help
him get his parents back by using the
family talent of disguise unfortunately
they don't seem able to disguise him as
a funny comedian when you around the
room
did you hear something that sounded like
this yes exactly that here's another big
problem I'm sorry I hate to pick apart
every little bit but bad comedy has to
be understood if it's not to be repeated
which I'm sure this film is gonna do a
lot of anyway slapstick is funny because
of cause and effect somewhere in the mix
somebody has to suffer that's the nature
of comedy now you can delay the reaction
or have the reaction happen to somebody
else but bottom line somebody has to be
in some form of misery Carvey however
throughout the entire film just smiles
this dumbass smile if he's not gonna be
hurt by any pain show the reaction of
the confused person trying to hurt him
that would be funny because they're not
getting the reaction they wanted or if
you're playing with the audience
expectation give a payoff or at least
some understanding that that's what
you're trying to do but nope dumbass
smile that's all we get get me some
man-sized meatballs
yeah if my mouth open makes up laughs
I'm baby geniuses if it must make him
laugh here look that face might
entertain your one-year-old for an hour
and a half but asshole you are on SNL I
mean it's like somebody chopping off my
head with a sword and nobody ever having
a reaction okay is this gonna be like a
thing with you seriously every single
time I make a joke am i good to look
behind my back and make sure you're not
gonna kill me well you know no I don't
know you're something very mixed signals
right now well I'll just go do that
Rachel Lee things I do so if you're
wondering why the hell doesn't just
grandpa go and save the parents well
it's because the ancient book of
disguiseys just a pop-up book a man says
he is not allowed if a father and mother
are missing only a son who is become a
master of disguise can save them without
any direct help from the grandfather but
of course direct help doesn't include as
much help as fucking humanly possible
what with him training his grandson
giving him all sorts of tools and
sharing everything he knows about
disguising but to be fair he'll need all
the help he can get as his father is
being forced by data oh wait this is
evil data so lured to use his disguises
to steal priceless artifacts or else
he'll kill his wife become a master of
disguise once again and helped me obtain
the world's rarest treasures
[Laughter]
okay I'll keep this movie 1 point for
making me laugh at a fart joke that's
actually very difficult to do what's
funny
but thank God our heroes are doing more
important things like dressing Carvey up
like an Indian Steve Carell the question
is not who I am the question is who are
you
I know who I am I'm Prince lolly Gemma
from the ringy-dingy Heights near Bombay
Calcutta in New Delhi India India India
cool fuck he's made him a guy from short
circular politically correct hey honey
what is for dinner anyone can put on the
disguise it changed his voice that's
another tall eulogy criticism of the
movie you know do you leave me no you
you seem to be doing well on your own
[Music]
you know here's just a notes on that
scene I took I think that about sums it
up but they better hurry for Lawrence
forcing Carvey's father to disguise
himself as the only celebrities this
movies budget could afford tricking
people into handing over priceless
treasures you've got serious masks head
[Laughter]
you've got me to laugh once
you got me to laugh once in a fart joke
a fucking fart joke and then what are
you doing you'll ruin it
you're totally just brilliant it flew
too close to the Sun on wings of
vigilance shame I know so it's decided
that the master of disguise needs an
assistant so they go ahead and put an ad
out for one well I was executive
secretary for Jensen and answer to your
question I have no idea what's wrong
with any of these applicants yeah I
really don't know he just tosses them
all up because they think a tracking
shot is funny maybe like the rest of the
film it assumes that can supply a decent
comedy by supplying no decent comedy but
the kitty comes across earlier turns out
to have a steaming hot mother of course
who also happens to be showing out to
apply for the job measurement what for
thank you for a uniform 35 24 34 mouth
open is too funny so she seems smart
intelligent and quick on her feet she
might be the perfect candidate except
for one problem her butt is too small no
really that's what they consider a
problem in this movie me like it but
this cat's got no mama caboose my great
a cooler did this be a no Jacobs go
ahead and let one cool of it people or
you know has this actress going on to
anything else okay good so she's doing
well in school
mm-hmm I'm gonna write her an apology
card anyway cuz Laura knows somebody has
to apologize to her deepest condolences
okay there we go yeah I mean I I know
we'll make up for it but you know just
something to eat
and some chocolates you know just
something nice to send her maybe she can
just look at and say hey it wasn't all
that bad got chocolates you know just
something to just sew and check you know
I mean for God's sake I mean it's I'm
sure she got paid but whatever she got
paid it it wasn't enough so they find a
cigar at the scene of the crime that
belongs to the turtle club so what does
he do
Teressa Boyken turtle of course no keep
in mind this is the image that appears
the most in all the advertising the
turtle guy this is the character that
they like to really push so obviously
this is the comedic highlight of the
movie this is what they want you to
remember the most and how does it go are
you a member of the turtle club am I not
totally enough for the turtle club okay
[Music]
the majority of the scene oh I take it
back there is one ball memory bytes a
guy's nose off so there's that but
otherwise there's nothing going on
except him shouting turtle turtle turtle
Charles no movie I I want to be serious
for a moment and I just want to ask in
all honesty nothing ironic no cynicism
nothing just straightforward man-to-man
what did you think was gonna happen here
and what was the mindset did you really
think that years later people were gonna
be looking back and
the the brilliance of the turtle scene
how did they do it turtle scene ungodly
genius so many various levels in which
it works we should pull it up to the
great comedic masters that come before
us who's our first crouch you in the
mirror Lucy in the chocolates fucking
turtle of course naturally I mean I
believe I actually saw that on Turner
Classic Movies when they were analyzing
the brilliant comedic writers of any
generation woman's not so much this
conception that one would perceive at
Tortola to be merely for roughhouse but
the fact that he repeats the word turtle
over and over I don't get it
no no he repeats the word turtle over
and over I still don't get it he repeats
the word turtle over and over I still
don't get it well fuck you I thought it
was funny so they traced the cigar back
to Laura's place which of course means
he'll have to Don another disguise oh
yeah
some people live from my misery oh yes
continue in the Mike Myers tradition of
being so wrapped up and how funny you
are that you barely even look the other
person in the face no mo no chicken
satay and get that little stick stuck in
my oh so I guess not a chance
okay now I'm going to ask you if you got
a little waiter and some tiny nuts sorry
you know I could tell just by looking at
you
you had your wiener
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
was like the last two minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah no I understand so um I might be
going away for a while after this review
it's just a heads up but wait you want
more annoying impressions without any
rhyme or reason don't worry there's
literally one two minutes away because
apparently the guards never realized
that if an obvious suspicious person is
around something fucking obvious and
suspicious is probably going on exchange
student at the University of hiders but
what two minutes is too long a time to
go without another one of these
irresistible characters
well how about 30 seconds yeah literally
thirty seconds later he's another
character the virial ding dong ding
indicating war not - I need a chance to
choo get it got it dumped it oh oh I did
receive a letter she received a letter
get it got it doubt it
that's my catchphrase I'm trying to
hammer it in I just know all these
characters are gonna have spin-off show
seeing how so well developed and
brilliantly written they are what was
that 80 seconds of screen time that's
more than enough to leave an impression
how me enough even with them getting
closer and closer to the villain they
never do seem to stop him from
continuing his evil plans maybe if they
spent a little more time for ting a
little less time mugging thoroughly
insane oh my god you're such a phony
again I'm not even joking that joke
actually became funny again this time
around it's like for all the terrible
humor going on this movie there's a
fascinating journey of this one joke in
like the peaks and valleys it's taking
in the evolution it's actually kind of
fascinating fart joke how do you do it
he just all part of the journey I simply
go and with the Golden Path maintained
well I certainly look forward to what
you discover next part joke piece be the
humor Corning's to youtube fart joke
[Music]
so Carvey asked for assistance from his
magic ancient ball yeah one of those is
in this now and he gets help from his
grandfather who just to clarify again
can't tell them I'm a pre-recorded
hologram what is your question I fear I
have not mustered enough energy co to
overcome our enemies
pistachio hoping you'd be here ha ha
that pre-recorded hologram somehow
seemed to know that a kid would enter
from the left and not be freaked out at
all that there's a giant scary head
hovering over him that's a good iced tea
so could a c8 Josh my wood he sneaks
into the bad guys hideout as a cherry
pie hopefully that's the only cherry
Dana Carvey ever popped and tries to
rescue his assistant and his father who
are apparently being auctioned off on
black mark eBay really fucking really he
does the exact same move three times
then that scares all the ninjas away one
move one fucking move
I mean it's like me using one move to
fight off Robocop in an Iron Man mask
with the Mariachi hat carrying a bow and
arrow with Doug's shoes no seriously
what is going on what is all this it's
my birthday
yeah but lore has another evil plan he's
glued a mask of himself on the Carvey's
father and is hypnotized him into
thinking he's really the villain I was
going to throw him off a cliff now fart
joke I have to admit that last one
wasn't as funny as the other ones
do not worry critic it is as I have said
before the journey of the five children
must flow whatever the wind may take
well I really hope your journey doesn't
end here for a joke I'd love for you to
keep exploring the possibilities of this
realm so do I put it so do I now I must
continue my travels
[Music]
Godspeed bro joke Godspeed but of course
Carvey convinces his father that he's
not lor and he shakes his mask off
that's a thing now but the fact remains
that the villain still got away so
through the means of no explanation
because we just wanted to get to the end
credits they discover where Laura is and
trick him by having Dana Carvey do the
only thing he was ever good at to begin
with
imitating bush a different bush this
time but don't worry the annoyance still
comes through would you mind if we had a
picture together
hmm I'll take your time now I'm ready is
it me or was Prince behind her trying to
transform into screech by the end of
this movie it's you shakes
oh yeah he knocks him out by lightly
tapping the side of his head and he
pulls into the pool she did her joke I'm
joking
that last one was terrible I know pretty
I know
but clearly my journey is all
is my smelly time in this world has come
to an end
Bert joke no we had such an incredible
journey together you've totally changed
my outlook I'm about humorous capable of
critical wise nano once there when the
story is over close the book did you
just quote the first Herbie movie maybe
goodbye my friend and remember I am the
breaking no fart joke no you can't leave
yet
so much more you can teach me
[Music]
goodbye Archer remember you
[Applause]
[Music]
god damn it Oh me you tell the fart joke
it's just when you think they couldn't
possibly kill anything else the movie
decides it also wants to kill our time
yeah just when you think it's time to go
home it turns out the movie is only an
hour and 12 minutes long God it feels
such an eternity longer but nevertheless
that's the running time so they
literally fill up eight minutes of
credits with bloopers alternate takes
deleted scenes they're pretty much
forcing you to watch all the special
features on the DVD because they know
for a fact
you'll never be interested enough in
seeing them it just keeps going and
going and going and going
this hipper than you are behind this is
the first giant yo-yo here we go there
we go - but you people are still doing
here you tell me asshole you're the one
keeping us hostage you just saw the
movie ok I'm trying to talk all right
goodbye
Hey all right so anyway ah there we go
ok is that in is that really in are we
truly done that no mom's dog
the worst it's amazing how unfunny it is
and what they confuse for comedy if you
keep your toddlers a camera and told
them to film something funny I bet you a
million bucks they will come up with
something funnier than this it's one of
the worst comedies of all time and for
good fucking reason even if it did have
that one joke that worked even the movie
found a way to kill it dead in its
tracks because that's what the movie
does it kills comedy and all I can say
is I'm gonna miss you fart joke I'm
gonna miss you I'm the Nostalgia Critic
it you kill my fucking fart joke we'll
remember my birthday
[Laughter]
[Music]
fired happy birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
you